the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of eight news now or next our
media group
voting is a right it's an absolute wreck
tonight on politics now will nevada's
elections get a new look the election
changes democrats want to make
and the response from republicans
there's still not
you know a credential pathway for them
regulating midwives the bills to put
some rules around midwives and help
mothers with at home births
plus we look at how nevada's coronavirus
numbers have stabilized
and the timeline for continuing to
reopen
from 8 news now this is politics now
thank you for joining us i'm john
langler stabilization in the coronavirus
fight nevada's mitigation task force
says coronavirus cases are starting to
level off
and the state says though it does not
expect to see any significant declines
in the near future
nevada's mass mandate will stay in place
when the state turns over control of
those restrictions to local governments
on may first
task force chair caleb cage says gaming
control will stay in control though of
casinos
however there is one question that's
still out there
will restaurants have to meet social
distancing and coronavirus requirements
moving forward
cage says that's still being reviewed
but the goal is to have a clear answer
early next week
i don't want to get down too into the
weeds of of um
of where we are on that because there's
there are decisions yet to be made
um but our goal
is to make sure we meet the uh the
spirit and the letter of the directive
going to
may 1st and local transition schools may
now apply to have large gatherings like
graduations for example those events
will also transition to county oversight
may 1st
vaccine eligibility expands on monday
to include everyone 16 and up
so let's look at the progress being made
in the pandemic fight this is a chart
here showing hospitalizations and you
can see here
this downward slide in fact they're now
at the lowest number
since the nevada hospital association
began keeping track of those cases
and hospitalizations now coveted cases
and deaths in nursing homes
as you see here also declining rapidly
you know nursing homes
are where most of the deaths happened in
nevada the american health care
association
says that deaths and hospitalizations as
you see here are down
more than 90 percent since the peak in
december
also governor steve sisolak has extended
the state's eviction moratorium through
the end of may
when landlords provide notices to
tenants during this time period
they must repeat they must also include
information on how they on available
rental assistance programs
and how tenants can access them help is
available for those in need
but only if they know about it we have
information about those rental
assistance programs at eightnewsnow.com
tenants have to provide documentation
showing they've been affected by the
pandemic
such as proof of income the governor
says this will be the last
statewide extension there is still no
timeline for lobbyists and the public to
go into the legislative complex the
houses
up in carson city staff previously said
they were aiming for early april which
is where we are now of course
when people can see the legislative
session in person though more security
measures will be in place there are
three new medical metal metal detectors
an x-ray machine and there are some
wands that are now in place as well for
security changing nevada's elections is
at the forefront of the legislature this
week
democrats in carson city are working to
make how we voted in november
permanent but republicans are not on
board they say the system is not secure
the i-team's david charns tells us what
is in this plan and how you can weigh in
democrats in carson city are pushing to
expand mail-in voting
permanently voting is a right it's an
absolute wreck
democratic speaker jason fryerson says
his bill ab-321
makes participating in our democracy
easier
and more secure and i think it's
incumbent upon us
to make sure that every eligible voter
has the ability to cast their ballot and
participate
we've seen in record numbers and as long
as nevadans are taking advantage of that
opportunity i believe that we need to
continue to make it available to them
the proposal would require you to opt
out rather than opt-in of getting a
mail-in ballot
so if you don't want one you won't get
one and you can still vote in person
the bill also cuts down the days ballots
are accepted after election day
from seven to four republican
assemblyman tom roberts says
it's a good start i mean those are
things that are certainly a move in the
right direction
whether or not it gets any or all of us
on board
remains to be seen robert says it should
be easy to vote but
he's concerned about fraud who could
fill out another person's ballot
and who could return them on another
person's behalf while the proposal
requires voter rolls to be scrubbed
every month
the assemblyman says that's not enough
for the simple fact that we have a
transit community in vegas
and a lot of people move and you got a
lot of ballots floating around and you
don't know
where they're at simply put fryerson
says the bill strengthens security
while expanding access when you have
record turnout we can't go back to
having
our senior standing in line for seven
hours to cast a vote this isn't a trip
to costco
this is a constitutional right david
charns 8 news now
democrats can still pass this without
any republican support
now as we mentioned this is one of
several election related bills up in
carson city right now
we here at eight news now have tried for
months to speak with secretary of state
barbara sagavski about measures that
would impact her office
staff have instead offered her deputies
however the person
actually elected to be the secretary of
state is according to her staff quote
not doing interviews at this time we'll
let you know if and when that changes
midwives provide care for mothers to be
and help deliver babies
in nevada though most aren't regulated
now lawmakers are looking to change that
this week the i-team reported on a
mother suing a midwife and members of
her team
she'd been pregnant with twins and lost
her firstborn during a home birth
both the mother and the defendants sat
down with the i-team to share different
versions of the same events
vanessa murphy explores the different
viewpoints on a hot button issue
and also looks at what changes may
happen here in nevada
you need a license to serve drinks and
cut hair in nevada but
not to care for moms to be and deliver
their babies in a home
there's still not a you know a
credential pathway for them
to basically to show the consumer
out there who might be wanting to do it
in home delivery
that there is a difference between
levels of midwives
republican state senator scott hammond
is introducing senate bill 271 to
license some midwives
there's also a similar bill being
considered in the assembly
opponents say it would take away a
mother's right to choose
some spoke out in this youtube video by
the group nevada friends of midwives
you're taking my right to choose who i
have at my birth away from me
so i feel safer at home choosing who can
attend my
births who can care for me and my babies
while some states issue and require
licensing or certification
nevada does not different national and
international organizations provide
certification
here's a look at the different kinds of
midwives
traditional midwives may not be
certified or licensed
certified nurse midwives are registered
nurses who are also educated in graduate
level midwifery programs
they have medical training some work
with physician groups and have
hospital privileges the state board of
nursing reports there are 64 certified
nurse midwives in nevada
a certified professional midwife has a
certificate through an organization like
the north american registry of midwives
executive director ida dara says that's
earned by passing a test and working
under the supervision of an experienced
midwife for prenatal visits newborn
exams and at least 55
births what would you say to critics who
say they're essentially
providing medical care without medical
training i would say they're providing
midwifery care
with midwifery training 100 deliveries
was the number of deliveries i did
my first month of my four years of
residency
first month dr stacy mchale is an ovgyn
in las vegas and the president-elect of
the clark county medical society
she says she supports a collaboration
between a midwife and physician
from the start the differences in the
levels of training are very
are very noticeable and those levels of
training
and the need to have expertise and the
need to have someone to provide
backup if there is an emergency
situation
is crucial for the health of our mothers
in nevada i have seen many of the
complications that can happen
with deliveries even those that we
anticipate are going to be normal
and having home birth midwives makes me
very anxious
what about those rare emergencies is it
worth taking a chance
nobody looks at their own pregnancy as
taking a chance i mean that's why you're
getting regular prenatal care and
assessment
so that you have a clue if anything is
uh
potentially problematic but could
something really
surprising come up it can come up and
that's why you need to address
what you will do if you have problems
like that right now nevada has no
oversight of any midwives through senate
bill 271
senator hammond is proposing the
creation of a board of certified
professional midwives
licensing for cpms and permits for
apprentices
with oversight there would be
regulations and
disciplinary action would be possible
while assembly bill
387 is similar it states if an
unlicensed person practices midwifery
they must obtain a statement from a
client acknowledging
they know the person is not regulated by
the state
if the midwife doesn't get that
statement they could be charged with a
misdemeanor crime
it also lists guidelines for when a cpm
must arrange for consultation with a
health care provider
what midwifery care is here in nevada
now
is unregulated and that's why it's
unsafe i hope it allows
consumers to have freedom of choice as
well as to have
midwives have a good path to getting
licensed
that is not too onerous for them to meet
the legislation is currently being
considered
no hearings have been scheduled yet
vanessa murphy
8 news now our i-team checked in with
local hospitals to find out whether they
have relationships with midwives and you
can find that information
over at eightnewsnow.com now the midwife
bill is among the top five getting the
most comments on the legislature's share
your opinion page
number one as you see on your screen
ab286 that's the so-called ghost gun
bill
it would ban guns without a serial
number it has 2749 comments
and more than those that are against it
number two sjr three
it encourages more wild house roundups
you can see there
it has more than 2300 comments in
support
assembly bill 19 changes what will be
included in high school civics classes
with now
almost 1500 comments in favor of it
assembly bill 141
seals eviction records during the
pandemic and increases how long they
take to process
it has more than 1300 comments this one
a bit closer though
with uh 745 in favor i believe it is
the midwife bill 938 comments 877 of
them
against republican assembly minority
leader robin titus is pushing a bill
that would let you
cook and eat roadkill istanbul 299
allows people to harvest roadkill on the
side of the road for their meet
dr titus says nevada is the only state
in the mountain west that does not allow
this
state game officials are worried though
a person could conceivably poach a big
game animal than just say it was
roadkill
nevada's department of transportation
estimates more than 5 000
wild animals are hit by cars in nevada
every year
bills that matter to your wallet coming
up on politics now proposals that could
have you spending less
and why they're opposed by big tech
welcome back
to politics now well you've probably
ordered more food delivery during the
pandemic
and now a bill proposed up in carson
city would cap fees from apps like
doordash and ubereats
those tech companies charge fees to
restaurants to use their platform senate
bill 320 caps that at 20 percent during
a state of emergency
local restaurants say right now those
apps can take as much as
30 percent the profit margins in a
restaurant so slim
and then on top of that you have to take
a third of the cut of that
the nevada restaurant association
supports the bill which also addresses
billing transparency
third-party platforms making commissions
public and menu stealing
doordash and other apps as you would
imagine oppose the bill
the company says fees help advertise and
market restaurants to new customers and
helps them out
another bill has big tech companies
facing off with
independent repair shop owners the right
to repair bill it's ab221
it would apply to consumer electronics
under five thousand dollars
if approved manufacturers would need to
give independent repair shops access to
parts and schematics needed to fix them
right now they only give that stuff to
authorized dealers
that would potentially drive down the
cost to get your phone or your tablet
fixed
similar right to repair initiatives are
also underway in two dozen other states
in minneapolis the murder trial of
former police officer derek chauvin
started this week
he is charged in the death of george
floyd meanwhile the intersection where
floyd died is a protest
zone the trial is expected to last a few
weeks
back here in southern nevada metro
sheriff joe lombardo discussed police
reform within his department after the
death of george floyd
the sheriff's multicultural advisory
council meets every month to talk about
race and issues of policing
members of that group pointed to metro's
work to improve issues of de-escalation
use of force and
other training to try and make a
difference in what officers do every day
sheriff lombardo told us these
conversations have to keep going
those things were in custody
incidents that we saw play out not only
with children there were some things
here
that took place as well that made us
really uncomfortable the fact that metro
will stand and listen
is important we're trying to teach the
officers to look at it from a different
paradigm
to slow down remove the emotion from the
equation
and get an understanding of the
situation before you rush in and
that's going to take a little while to
change of course las vegas saw
protests and riots last year after
floyd's death
sheriff lombardo has asked for peace and
calm no matter how the verdict in
minneapolis
turns out from nevada to texas former
nevada congressional candidate
dan rodimer drawing criticism for his
new texas cowboy look
we'll have that coming up in just a few
moments on politics now plus alexander
limon
tells us what is in president joe
biden's economic recovery plan
you're watching politics now
southern nevada's congressional
delegation was back at home this week
helping pitch the biden administration's
american rescue plan
democratic congresswoman susie lee held
an event with clark county sheriff
joe lombardo who you see in the
background there lee says
billions of dollars are going to come to
our state from that package
the coronavirus relief bill was passed
more than a month ago
it includes funding for vaccinations and
emergency financial relief
congresswoman lee says it has direct
investments right here in southern
nevada
i'm proud to report that under the
american rescue plan
we will help nevada build back better by
bringing 2.95
billion dollars in aid to our state
government
1.14 billion to local governments
1.1 billion dollars to k to 12 education
and of course up to fourteen hundred
dollars in economic stimulus payments to
anyone earning under seventy five
thousand dollars
the sheriff was there because some of
the money that is coming here
will go to police and fire departments
president biden says his new american
recovery plan will help the economy come
back from the pandemic
this week he unveiled an ambitious
proposal at a press conference in
pittsburgh total cost of this plan for
infrastructure
2.3 trillion dollars president biden
says this will add millions of jobs
democrats are on board republicans
are not every community large and small
rural suburban and urban will benefit
from this robust
american jobs plan just within the last
year that comes to a
total combined spending of 10 trillion
dollars and
all of it's been paid for by the largest
tax increase in the history of the
united states
joining us to talk about the
infrastructure plan from the white house
alexander limon from our washington dc
bureau alex it is good to see you
let's talk quickly about what is in the
president's infrastructure bill
yeah well the president's infrastructure
package is really a massive one totaling
2.3
trillion dollars about one quarter of
that would go toward modernizing and
fixing the
transit system so roads bridges railways
but the rest goes toward
other types of infrastructure projects
for example replacing all of the lead
pipes to provide
safe drinking water infrastructure
expanding access to
affordable housing and then there's also
expanding broadband access you know we
really have learned over the past year
that that's become
critical infrastructure so that's
another portion of this bill
and then there are significant
investments in clean energy that would
be made about 100 billion dollars would
go toward
modernizing the nation's power grid and
making it more
resistant to climate disasters to try to
avoid things like what we just recently
saw happen
in texas for example but also shifting
the nation overall to a cleaner greener
energy supply and doing things like
investing in electric vehicle charging
stations for example all across the
nation
it is certainly a comprehensive and
ambitious the trump administration the
last administration
referenced infrastructure during its
time in office
are republicans at all positive about
what the biden administration is
proposing how are they reacting
well yeah everyone it's kind of the joke
on capitol hill right everyone always
says they want to get infrastructure
done but
it never actually gets done and i think
the fundamental problem here is that
there are different ideas of
what infrastructure means republicans
say this bill goes much too far and
extends into areas that aren't typically
considered
infrastructure and their other big issue
with it is that they say it is just
very expensive too expensive for what
they're trying to do
because in addition to this 2.3 trillion
dollars you know the government has just
recently already spent
trillions of dollars to deal with the
pandemic so
republicans say that we just can't
afford to pass such a massive bill
um and the other issue with it is that
in order to pay for it president biden
is proposing
i guess what we're calling tax increases
but what it really does is undo the tax
cuts that republicans passed in 2017 but
that was
probably the single largest and most
successful piece of legislation
that republicans and the trump
presidency passed
so i don't see it as something that
they're very likely to vote to
undo and of course that was alex limon
from washington
dc you're watching politics now
former nevada congressional district 3
candidate dan rodimer has moved
to texas and he's running for congress
there his ads are drawing a lot of
attention
three dirtiest jobs in the world
professional wrestling
politician and blue riding
hood so road armor lost to congresswoman
susie lee for the race for congressional
district 3.
well the republican is now running for
texas's sixth district
critics in texas accuse him of affecting
a fake accent in this video you're
seeing there
rodimer also used body doubles for the
bull ride segment of the ad
we'll keep you posted on that race in
texas finally
you know we focus on nevada politics
here but what do you want to tell you
about something happening
in oklahoma in the legislature there
there's a measure that sets up a two
million dollar
bounty for someone who can catch bigfoot
alive the goal to boost tourism
it's just been astronomical uh what
response we've had
some of those people concerned and i've
tried to set their mind to these
that hey this is all about tourism this
is all about bringing people
in to see our area we'll keep posted on
that too
thanks for watching we'll see you next
[Music]
time
you